a growing number of women are choosing
not to have kids and as a result are
advancing in their careers and using
their wealth to buy property and travel
more this is an article by Bloomberg I
think came out of their business week
Edition Ashley mararo isn't married and
doesn't have kids and she has a message
for women just like her you can still
have it all I love my life and feel very
fulfilled says marara who froze her eggs
in 2018 to keep her options open the 43
year old feels a deep sense of
satisfaction from her job as a sales
representative for a maker of medical
devices which brings her into contact
with patients and she relishes all of
the lifestyle and financial freedoms
that come with being a single Child free
woman in a well-paying job mararo who
was married for four years before
getting divorced in 2008 enjoys an
enviable degree of financial
Independence the West Village resident
owns her own apartment she bought in
2019 for around 900 000 and then
renovated and in June she closed on a
summer home in New Jersey's Long Beach
Island with her sister Christina who's a
few years older and also single with
Nokia kids Ashley figures she's taking
10 trips in the last 12 months and often
friends with a large group of about 25
people who were largely unmarried and
don't have children those trips at 43
sound like they suck I do not want to go
on that trip
frankly
yeah so everything you just described
there is kind of like a a symptom of
what I would call The Wider amazing
crisis and it seems to be like a
cultural kind of prioritizing of the
male default of economic success the
kind of girl boss lean in kind of
culture seems to be set up as what uh
the vision for success for women tends
to be and yet you have a lot of even
corporate Giants kind of getting in on
this
um a few years ago you had Morgan
Stanley the investment bankers put out a
report that forecasts that 45 of prime
working age women between the ages of 25
and 44 will be single and childless by
2030 the largest share in history and
it's not entirely obvious to me that
this is in women's best interest I mean
I'm pretty libertarian in my
sensibilities about you know freedom of
choice for whatever someone wants to do
with their life and but it it seems to
me like a you can see the kind of
corporate interest in opening up more
worker drones for 60 hour work weeks and
you know the the workplace now women are
crushing it it's a brain-based economy
rather than a Brawn based economy so
that that seems to be in their interests
and it's weird it's like it's almost
like Huxley and it's like Brave New
World have you read that Chris yes yeah
so it's very Huxley and it's like
um this kind of hedonistic life of going
on lots of trips having very atomized
type of sex single Hood will be on the
rise you won't get attached to any one
person you'll own nothing and you'll be
happy that that kind of thing and it
seems a little bit dystopian to me
um to kind of you know to hurtle towards
that uh dystopian Vision but uh that
that's the the modern amazing crisis we
find ourselves in and uh yeah that
that's where we are why do you think
this male default has come about because
it's something that I've noticed as well
the typically masculine traits are the
ones that would have been held by men
the conscientiousness disagreeability
the Casual Sex the ability to move on
and not really catch feels and not be
emotional to focus on possessions and
drive fast cars what what is it that's
causing that to be imbibed by women and
also pushed to them by culture so
actually women are generally a bit more
conscientious than men and but yeah I
agree with you that it's kind of
flipping to that default and I think it
is just a an organic backlash to kind of
uh what we might describe as the
historic oppression of women
socioeconomically uh you know it's kind
of a leaning into that freedom almost at
too fast a pace it's like one speed go
foot to the floor on girl bath mode
um and you know you have the corporate
Giants kind of playing into that and uh
yeah it's just a kind of a situation
where for the first time maybe in
history men and women aren't relying on
each other as obviously as in the past
um and yeah that it's kind of more
individualistic kind of world now we're
kind of uh you know atomized and away
from our kin in big cities across the
world which is very evolutionarily novel
and so yeah I think it's just a an
ordinary uh somewhat expected backlash
to maybe the oppression of the past like
the uh child of the Christian parents
that moves out and immediately gets a
nose piercing and a bunch of tattoos and
swings back the other way okay
continuing on with that article single
women without kids had an average of 65
000 in wealth in 2019 compared with 57
000 for single child-free men
single women without kids 65 000
57 000 for single Child free men so we
already have something there that kind
of pushes back against the commonly held
uh world view uh the difference is for
single mothers the figure was only seven
thousand dollars Parenthood was losing
its appeal even before covid-19 U.S
birth rates have been falling for the
past 30 years in 1990 there are around
71 births per year for every thousand
women aged 15 to 44 by 2019 that had
dropped to 58 so from 71 to 58 which is
a pretty big drop some women opting not
to have kids are enjoying an enviable
degree of Financial Freedom she's got
all of her different houses the
childless life does have its drawbacks
people who are single and Child free pay
more in taxes and housing is a lot
harder to afford than one income than
two especially with home prices and
rents at record high and mortgage rates
on the rise so
that's the problem that Bloomberg can
find with potentially going to your
grave with no one else that's part of
your genetic kin there to to see you is
the fact that you're going to pay more
in in taxes and housing is more
difficult to afford yeah it's very
corporate kind of language isn't it that
the main concern would be how do we get
around that that one stumbling block of
the taxes
um but I was glad that she did at least
highlight uh the idea of buying a house
on a single income because that's
something I always highlight for in
sales that that's a double Kwame kind of
a circular punishment it's hard to get a
house uh if you're a single man on one
income and a lot of incels are on lower
income or no income at all and you
almost need to be part of a good
learning household to get a mortgage so
without the house you can't get the
girlfriend without the girlfriend you
can't get the house so it feels like a
little bit of a circular punishment for
incels there
um but yeah that's a you can hear the
corporate language dripping in in in
that account it's it really does rile me
up man the fact that women who choose to
be mothers are being seen as
second-class Rubes that have been I
don't know gazumped into taking a role
that was just some ancestral old version
of what Womanhood was supposed to be you
can go out and be a boss [ __ ] you can
get over your last boyfriend by getting
under your next one like
all of this sort of rhetoric to me
doesn't sound massively empowering
Louise Perry's book case against the
sexual Revolution is phenomenal at this
like Loveless sex is not empowering and
teaching women that they should be able
to try and compete with men on having
Loveless sex only one gender is going to
win that right it's not going to be the
women men are going to continue to run
through girls when they can and leave
them behind and
I don't know I just feel like there
needs to be the push battle the swing
back against
past disadvantages that women have had
is not making women's lives any better I
think that you can comfortably say that
enabling women to earn more in the
workplace was fantastic the vote the
pill the washing machine all of this
stuff like things that genuinely
liberated women from the previous
constraints that they had were Worthy
I struggle to see how encouraging women
to see the new pair of Gucci shoes that
they've got that they buy from a job
that they hate to impress people that
they don't like as being the highest
point of contribution of their life and
that the mothers are somehow
second-class citizens yeah yeah and it
certainly is like it almost seems like a
concerted war on motherhood even last
week there was a an article or over the
weekend in the New York Times about the
myth of the maternal Instinct and it
talked about how uh you know this this
is a man-made phenomenon culturally kind
of a cultural script that we all buy
into and people were just highlighting
how ridiculous this is now I think there
might be a little bit of I can give a
little bit of a charitable
interpretation to that article uh in
that the myth of maternal Instinct isn't
just one thing so maternal instinct is
probably more accurate so maternal
instincts could sometimes depending on
the age of the woman uh her marital
situation or socioeconomic stages that
maternal Instinct might even be
infanticide so you know it's a it's a
suite of instincts that are kind of
activated in in different situations
like all of our evolved psychology it's
not it's not just on or off it's just in
which environment it comes uh on play
as I said over dinner the other evening
that is way way too much of a charitable
interpretation that person that wrote
that article doesn't even know what
you're on about and you've extrapolated
out this it speaks to your good nature
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for a selection of
the best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]